[MUSIC PLAYING]
CASSIE KOZYRKOV:
Hello and welcome.
We're here at the Security Zone
at Google Next with Prajakta,
who is one of Google's
leading experts in denial
of service attacks.
Hi, Prajakta.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: Hi, Cassie.
And thank you for having me.
CASSIE KOZYRKOV:
When companies deploy
internet-facing services,
one of the biggest problems
they encounter is denial
of service attacks.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: So our
customers have a tough job.
They want to quickly and
responsively serve their end
users and, at the
same time, they
need to defend their
internet facing services
against malicious attacks.
And denial of service attacks
are getting much larger,
they're getting much
more sophisticated,
and security teams need
to be prepared for them.
So let's look at an example.
Let's say you're
the infrastructure
manager for an online
retailer and it's
Black Friday, the busiest
day of the year for you,
and you've got an important job.
You need to make sure that
the website and apps stay up
and running.
So Black Friday has
started, and here, we
can see all of the successful
transactions represented
as boxes coming into
the application servers.
Everything looks to be
running smoothly now,
but let's see what happens
once an attack is launched.
CASSIE KOZYRKOV: Awesome.
Do your worst.
SPEAKER: The first attack
I'm going to launch
is a high volume DDoS attack.
I'm going to use this to try
and overwhelm the servers
with malicious traffic.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: We can see that
the application instances are
being overwhelmed by
the malicious traffic
from the attacker's servers.
CASSIE KOZYRKOV: If
this amount of traffic
keeps hitting the
application instances,
they'll get overloaded,
and they'll go down.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: That's correct.
Shoppers on the
website are already
getting a slow load
time and the website
is going to start crashing.
Now, as the
infrastructure manager,
you do have some tools at
your disposal to manage this.
What do you think would be the
best way to go handle this?
CASSIE KOZYRKOV: I'm going to
go with infrastructure DDoS
protection using Google
Global Load Balancer.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: Great choice.
After you enable the Google
Global Load Balancer,
the application instances
are back up and running
and shoppers are
now able to access
the site without a problem.
Now, in this example, you
turned on this defense
in the middle of a live attack.
But in reality, you would
have actually already set up
your services behind the
Global Load Balancer,
prior to Black Friday.
But Black Friday isn't over yet.
In fact, our shoppers
are just getting started.
Let's see what happens
when the attacker launches
an application attack this time.
SPEAKER: This time, I'm going to
launch a SQL injection attack.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: So
now our attacker
is sending in SQL injection
packets in an attempt
to bring down our
service and steal data.
With SQL injection
one little flaw
in one little feature
of your application
can compromise all
the data for your app.
Again, you've got some
tools at your disposal.
What do you think is a
good defense for this type
of attack?
CASSIE KOZYRKOV: I'd pick Cloud
Armor SQL Injection Defense.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI:
Good choice, again.
This Cloud Armor rule
acts as a defense
to these types of attacks
by automatically identifying
malicious SQL injection packets
and blocking them before they
hit your application instances.
Without Cloud Armor
you would have
to first detect SQL
injection attack,
and then react, remediate, and
also fix your code and data.
CASSIE KOZYRKOV: Got it.
So this means just
enabling this single rule
would defend our app against
all SQL injection attacks.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: That's correct.
But the day isn't done yet,
and our sophisticated attacker
is going to come at us again.
SPEAKER: For this
last attack, I'm
going to use a
multi-vector attack, which
is going to hit the
application instances using
multiple different types of
attack vectors all at once.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: Now, we can see
that a multi-vector attack is
hitting the servers and
trying to take them out.
And it looks like
all of this traffic
is coming from one region.
Again, the service
is slowing down
and our shoppers aren't
able to submit their orders.
After analyzing this
attack, we find out
that it's coming from a single
location with a specific type
of cookie and user agent.
CASSIE KOZYRKOV: Aha.
So maybe we could
create a custom rule
in Cloud Armor that looks
for this cookie and user
agent in the traffic
coming from the region?
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: Exactly.
That's correct.
Now you see the Cloud
Armor custom rule
blocking the
traffic that matches
our specified pattern, which
helps keep our service up
and running.
CASSIE KOZYRKOV:
I feel like now I
know a lot more about what
our retail customers have
to deal with on Black Friday.
I have a lot more
empathy for them.
It's pretty challenging.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: With
Google Cloud's tools
to help defend and scale
against this infrastructure
and application denial of
service attacks in place,
you can actually focus on
building great software
and great customer experiences.
CASSIE KOZYRKOV: Thanks
so much for walking us
through this demo, Prajakta.
And thank you, [? Srina, ?]
for this very admirable attack
attempt.
SPEAKER: Thank you.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: Thank you
for having me, Cassie.
[MUSIC PLAYING]